[Music]
one addition to picking a president
people here in California have to vote
on a whole bunch of ballot measures yeah
and they've been running ads through
these ballot propositions around the
clock I gotta say some of these are
pretty confusing big business and
struggling families alike are united on
Proposition 53 from 53 will reduce class
sizes and generate over a billion
dollars in tax cuts so I should vote Yes
on Prop 53 No voting YES on from 53
would put thousands of firefighters out
of work and make it easier to evict
families of active military troops from
their homes and the millions it saves
goes right to the keh keh keh
so no 153 no voting no on Prop 53
triggers a crippling gas tax allows
convicted felons to County shows and
eliminates freeway guardrails and home
stands to profit
okay so don't vote on Prop 53 at all
that'll just make it Angry
you can't ignore prop 53 but you can
trick it take a pen and turn the
number-3 into an eight
now it's Proposition 58 a measure that
would close and we'll kill shelters and
replace them with the first-ever Six
Flags for obvious it's your choice
California paid for by citizens against
the mere existence of brown 53
[Applause]
just buckety
those puppies look so happy on their you
gotta go 58